okay so thanks everyone for coming yes
I'm going to talk about new tricks for
expander codes and so I'm going to talk
about two recent papers which the union
of the authors is here so joint work
with Brett hemenway and Rafi ostrovsky
okay so let me give you the the one
slide version of the talk because we're
getting started a little late and I'm
right between you and lunch so it's a
you can see the one slide version and
then sneak out and I won't be offended
so here's the one slide version so I'll
define expander codes in a little bit
but basically you can make an expander
code out of some inner code and an
expander graph and expanded codes have
been around for a while since the 90s
and there's been a long and beautiful
line of work sort of exploring them
starting with sips earn Spielman and
other work by bargains more and the
basic punch line of this line of work is
right here so if the inner code has
decent distance then your expander code
has decent distance and it's decodable
in linear time so it admits a very fast
decoding algorithm can expand the coast
so we gave me why would you like them oh
because they have very fast decoding
algorithms yeah so that that's why they
were originally introduced is this punch
line so linear time decoding algorithms
with the original selling point but
today I'll give you a few more selling
points so this talk extends this sort of
thing more generally so the moral that I
want to get across is that if the inner
code has decent something something then
so does the expander code and there's an
efficient decoding algorithm so that's
the high-level point and the two
examples that all give our one about
locally correcting code cells so that if
the inner code has decent locality and I
need to define decent then so does the
expander code and it's locally decodable
actually locally correctable just to say
it i can actually correct it in sub
linear time so that's efficient and the
next example is that if the inner code
has decent list recoverability which I
also define it in it then so does the
expander code and its list recoverable
in linear time so right metric
punchlines so let me give a brief
overview of what that means and the
types of results we get and I'll sort of
zoom in and detail as the top goes along
but so here's a slightly less zoomed out
version so what we can get for locally
correctable codes for expander codes so
local correction very briefly means that
I can correct one symbol by looking just
at just a few other symbols and so we've
heard a lot about local recoverability
like in the last talk this model is a
little bit different because there are
errors so it's a harder model and what
we get in in this harder model is codes
with rate going to one and the number of
queries you need to make the locality is
enter the epsilon where n is the block
length of the code so it's smaller than
n and the other thing I'm going to talk
about is listrik of herbal codes so list
recoverability very briefly means that
instead of errors I have some sort of
uncertainty and I'll quantify that more
in a bit and what we get here is codes
with again high rate codes right tending
to one and with a linear time recovery
is the lash line and one reason that
it's nice to get codes with both of
these things with rate tending to one is
that we can plug them into an approach
of mirror and so he has kind of a
similar sort of moral theorem to the one
that I gave on the previous slide so his
morale theorem is that given codes with
something or other in high rate then you
can get codes with something rather that
approach the singleton bound using a
very nice construction actually
originally sort of modified from one of
a alone and movie and so when we plug
these sorts of results into this
machinery we get sort of results with
sort of the optimal rate error trade-off
in both of these models
that's it broad overview are the new
codes of our larger field I know so
whatever the field sizes of the inner
code or whatever the alphabet sizes of
the inner code the outer coat has the
same alphabet oh sorry after I run them
through this yes they do have a larger
larger alphabet size yet that as they
must disagree ok so that's a very high
level overview now I want to get back to
your question which is why should we
care ok so here's a some of the selling
points you know with all the flashy
colors from why we might care about some
of those previous results so with
locally correctable codes this gives a
sublunary time to coding of expander
codes it also gives a new construction
of high rate lccs so we know how to get
these before there's been a couple
constructions known but this is a new
and different construction of those for
the list recoverable codes these
trade-offs we actually didn't know how
to get them before with linear time
recovery so this is something new
locally or sorry list list recover Bo
codes are sort of interesting and their
own right there also related to other
problems like they're very related to
list decoding many lists decoding
algorithms are secretly list recovery
algorithms they're also recently have
been used in group testing compressed
sensing algorithms so there they've been
useful there one one caveat is that our
error model is a little bit different
than the ones that are useful in this
regime so we can't immediately think
we're gonna talk about something you're
thinking of that you just want to figure
one bit exactly yeah yeah another reason
you might care which i think is maybe
more important than these is is this
general moral so like I said in my
five-minute talk three examples will
make a theorem so now i have three
examples of start with inner code with
decent blog and an expander code with
sufficient the same thing so i hope that
there are more examples in this regime
but the actually the main reason that
i'm talking about this problem in this
audience the from theory to practice
thing is that i think why do we care is
is still largely an open problem
and so this is what I want to ask you
guys like so so here's a bunch of
reasons why I might care but there's I
think that there are lots of other
reasons why we could care that I don't
know yet and so in particular I'm
interested in sort of what are other
things that I can fit into this sort of
folk theorem yeah we've heard of lots of
desert dorada that we might like from
codes which are maybe not so standard so
so far in this workshop a local recovery
and lots of other things are useful in
practice and I'm wondering if there's
anything there that that could help here
also more concretely like i said this
error model isn't immediately useful for
the applications that i know of for list
recovery but maybe their applications
that you know of where it is useful in
that case i'd love to hear it too so we
heard a couple of compelling talks
earlier about why an eraser like model
is useful at so good right here yeah
which often will trade offs yeah so we
use ramanuja and graph and that we have
explicit ones of those yeah so these are
all fully completely explicit
constructions yeah sunoco go shoot
silver yes you can only prove expansion
of some about right you can get a better
expanders but it's only provable what is
an extension of half what kind of
expansion so here I'm talking about
spectral expansion which I'm going to
measure in terms of the the second
eigenvalue of the normalized laplacian
matrix vertex reg expansion as well yeah
there is yeah um it's up to her okay so
what's surprising is that for some of
the old expander of that results you
need actually expansion higher than that
eighty two thirds so for example like
the original what is it citrus pony you
can't prove error correction with Rama
dejan expanders you can only prove it
with expansion two-thirds ah okay you
might have a different proof of that yes
I'm the stuff that we're building on is
the version of expander codes that come
from some more and so he uses uh yeah
just just the spectral expansion and
there we
it is enough we can talk more about this
offline but yeah BSO all our results are
in terms of the spectral expansion terms
the second eigenvalue and we don't need
the comet Oriole expansion guarantees we
only need the special which we do know
how to get explicitly other questions
about why anyone might care okay cool
alright so now that we all care let me
give you some more details um okay so
first time you tell you what an expander
code is so well I'll tell you what a
Tanner code is and then I will tell you
what an expander code is such a special
cases at Anika so the Tanner code is
obtained by a graph ad regular graph on
n vertices and an inner code which will
have length D and here we should think
of n is going to infinity and D as being
some something independent of n like 10
some constant and from these two
ingredients this D regular graph and
this inner code we're going to get an
expander code and it's going to have
length ND over to the number of edges in
the graph ok and code words are going to
be a I'm going to think of them as
labelings of edges of my graph so what
what constitutes a code word of this
tanner code so a labeling of the edges
of my graph is in my expander code if
the labels on each vertex form a code
word in the inner code so that is to say
so here's a labeling so I'd say my
alphabet Assize to hear so I've labeled
all the edges of my expander code and
this is a legitimate code word and the
this labeling corresponds to a code were
in the expander code if for every vertex
I've sort of ordered the vertices or the
edges coming out arbitrarily if those
guys form a code word in the inner code
so here I actually worked this out this
is a code word when the inner code is a
743 Hamming code
so this is a legit code word and it's
not hard to see that if the inner code
is linear then so is the expander code
basically I had all these linear
constraints for my inner code and now
I'm just imposing those constraints sort
of locally on the vertices so now I have
a stolen of your code and moreover by
counting these constraints you can
figure out the rate if my rate started
it or not then my new rate is going to
be 2 R naught minus 1 work that up and
if G is an expander graph then i'm going
to call this an expander code and and
here if you know about expander is great
and if not it's just it's a some low
degree graph that's very well connected
and like I was saying la well we could
just take G to be a ramen ocean graph
and we have any cool for any trouble any
D regular graph this is true this debate
might be because I think it strange yeah
yeah yeah sorry with rate at least this
the right the rate might be bigger um
but uh I was really good- this for small
as you oh yeah no yes so the rate is at
least this it does not go down to
negative one yeah thanks yeah and I
think so what you're saying is that
often it's the case that for these
expander codes I won't use an expander
path i'll use the double cover of an
expander graphs of some sort of
bipartite version and we can move back
and forth between them for this talk i'm
just going to assume that i just have a
non bipartite version just for ease of
figures but you're right in the papers
we do use a better so that's those are
expander codes any any questions yes sir
call me yes
yes indeed and in fact I will show you
how to take advantage of some that
locality now so locally correcting
expander codes yeah so now let me give
you a brief overview of this yeah so
what do I mean by local correction so
we've seen a couple of models of you
know what we might want from locality so
far it's the local recovery and stuff
like that this is a little different
model so here there are errors so Alice
has some code word that she wants to
send to Bob there it is some bad guy
introduces some errors adversarial E and
now Bob's job and the bad guy also tells
Bob recover me this symbol tell me what
that was supposed to be and Bob's job is
now to query a couple of positions and
figure out what that what that symbol
should have been and in this case he
wins he successfully realizes that it
should be a note so that's the
definition of locally correctable codes
slightly more formally we say that a
code is Q Delta locally corruptible if
Bob can do this when the adversary gets
to introduce a delta fraction of errors
and Bob makes q queries and the queries
are randomized and we want him to be
able to succeed with high probability
over the choice of his
so how can we take advantage of this for
expander codes so here's the theorem we
get this is an informal version again
it's just before lunch I don't want to
slam you guys with notation but uh
morally speaking this is what we can
show if you have an inner code which has
some kind of locality which I will call
nan robust but smooth which basically
means I can reconstruct any symbol in
many ways but I do not need to be able
to tolerate errors in this
reconstruction so it's not itself a
locally correctable code but it has some
locality and I take a ramanuja graph as
my expander with large enough degree in
terms of all of the parameters that have
been floating around then the expander
goed that I get from combining these two
ingredients is a locally correctable and
the number of queries I need is n to the
epsilon here I think I haven't defined
the soy capital n is the number of edges
in my graph so it's in Ebbetts block
length of my code and delta is the
amount of error I can tolerate and
unfortunately for us this is rather
small so it's 1 over poly cute but it's
some constant depending on the locality
of the original and we can instantiate
this with some particular codes that we
get from a fine geometries and the punch
line is that we can get codes with rate
approaching one that are entered the
epsilon Delta local correctable and
again here Delta depends on an alpha and
epsilon in some polynomial way and like
I said we can also shove this through
this construction of mirror and get
codes and actually this was his original
motivation for this construction is
turning high rate locally correctable
codes into something like this you can
get sort of the optimal trade off so you
can get codes that approach the
singleton bound and they're locally
crushable too so just a quick little you
here so getting codes in this regime was
is not new we knew of a couple of
families of high rate local locally
correctable codes before but this is a
pretty different construction these
are all algebraic and this is really not
so so so this is a wonderful parties
yaqaan instead of construction you're
citing the multiplicity codes is this a
different result from a teaser honey uh
oh no I just forgot to write soon as you
can and I'm sorry sir again that's not
garden I got bored eppa typing figure
out where the HS go okay sorry uh
apologies know that that is yeah just my
life humble oh okay yes I are there any
other questions before I move on okay so
that now let me move on to a linear time
list recovery of expander codes how am i
doing for time oh start of the late so
um it's between 10-15 minutes okay all
right well people can walk out at noon
if I feel like analysis okay so let me
talk briefly about this list recovery
problem so the list recovery problem is
different it is a slightly different
error model so before we had this error
model where a bad guy gets to introduce
errors now we have an error model where
the back I guess to introduce
uncertainty so here's you know Alice's
code word hello how are you is there but
the the bad guy has been there that the
adversary is is able to has given some
list of possibilities in each position
with the guarantee that the intended
symbol is in that list and we can make
it life a little harder for Alice and
Bob maybe there are some positions that
we just don't nothing about it and now
Bob strategy is to Bob's goal is to look
at these lists or lack thereof and try
to recover the original code word in
this case he has to recover a list he
can't recover just the code word itself
because you know what if I took
one code word here one code word here
one code word here he'd have to have
list sighs at least three so mom's job
is to recover a short list in this case
sighs three are bigger not too much
bigger that contains the correct code
word so again more formally we say that
the code is now there are three
parameters to keep track of alpha little
L and Big L list recoverable from
erasers if for any set of lists which
have size at most little L so little L
here is three there are at most capital
L code words so that would be the size
of Bob's list that agree in all the
lists given and I'm allowed I need to
have lists in an alpha fraction of a
position so 1 minus alpha fraction I'm
allowed to put boxed remarks so this is
a slightly different definition of Lists
recovery then is often given it's a
little bit weaker model so that's why
I've qualified at Lystra coverable from
erasers this is a definition that was
given an engrossing and in dec or an
instant work of guru Swami and in dec
but it's that there are other error
models i might say that these question
marks aren't aren't in fixed locations
but rather i just need to agree with it
we cannot handle that error model right
now ok so it's the definition clear
yeah and so I should mention the list
recoverability is related to like i said
before list of coding and is useful in a
lot of other things okay and so what is
our result so same type of setup if we
have a inner code that is lister
coverable former racers an expander
graph of degree D which needs to be big
enough then the outer code is also
Lister covetable from Eire ratios and we
can instantiate this in this case we can
stand she ate with random linear codes
to get a trade-off like like this so we
get rates tending to one and list
recovery from erasures with constant
list sizes and again shoving this
through the same construction of or
mirror we get basically the optimal
trade-off here so for any rate we can we
need lists only in an R plus epsilon
position and you can show that this rule
and just a again a brief lit review so
previously your time constructions had
low rate and previous high rate
constructions had super linear time
decoding so polynomial time where the
exponent on polynomial is like 1 over
epsilon or 1 over epsilon squared or
something like that so this is much
faster so this is the first construction
to obtain sort of the best of both
worlds linear time constructions with oh
yeah linear time recovery with high rate
so am I remaining ten minutes or so I
want to give a flavor of the algorithms
that are used so here's a here's how the
list recovery algorithm goes so I'll
just so what is the list recovery
problem again we have these like lists
on each edge so here's one vertex in my
graph a bunch of edges coming out of it
we have lists on each edge and I want to
figure out I want to find a list of
possible code words that are consistent
with all the information given so the
first step is just to list recover
locally at every vertex the inner code
is locally recoverable so I can do this
so I get some possible list of code
words of the inner code that might
belong on these symbols so now let's do
a little thought experiment let's
suppose that we just decided that this
symbol was an a it could be an A or a B
but let's just say we're going to decide
it's an a so then well what do we know
right we we look at this list may be the
this is the position that corresponds to
that edge maybe there are a couple of
code words that have an a in them so now
we've narrowed down the number of code
words okay so it's either this one or
this one it's not this guy in the middle
okay so that's great but actually we
even have more information than that if
we look at say this position here which
corresponds to that edge you know we
don't know which of these two code words
it is but we do know that for sure that
position has a d in it right and
similarly there probably a bunch of
other positions like this also so the
moral the story is if I decide
arbitrarily that this symbol is a that
determines a bunch of other edges
and that's basically the whole algorithm
so I make one decision that determines
some other edges making those decisions
determine some more edges and so on and
because this is an expander we hope this
will propagate out pretty fast and cover
a lot of the graph a constant fraction
the graph then we repeat we make another
decision that will determine some more
edges and so on we repeat this a
constant number of times until we've
covered almost all of the graph at which
point we can correct the rest of the
edges using the normal decoding
algorithm for expanders and the number
of possibilities that we have at the end
of the day is l2 the number of these
yellow edges right so that's sort of the
number of the number of possibilities I
had if I only had to make these
decisions I can make all possible
decisions and get a short list the
length of my list is out of a constant
that's that's basically the whole
algorithm and then you have to do some
work to show that this actually works
but and let me I'll just really quickly
give a flavor of the local decoding
algorithm which is super easy cuz it's
exactly the same animation all right so
let's say I want to know this edge now
my inner code is locally correctable so
like you're pointing out that have some
locality here I can use these two edges
to determine the symbol that's supposed
to go on that edge and I can use now I
want to know this edge i can use two
more symbols to learn the value that
goes on that edge and so on and the
algorithm is now basically will create
query that tree more or less with some
caveats
and so that now that's basically it and
you have to show that we can actually
reconstruct the value that goes on this
edge from this tree even if there are
errors and this takes a little bit of
work but the basic idea is that suppose
that I had two trees and I'm trying to
decide which one is the truth so I have
some error e version of one of these
trees and this one has a different
symbol on the route than this one well
then this they also must differ in one
of the children of the root because this
because of the locality and then they
also must differ down there so they must
differ from entire path from like the
root to the leaf of this tree and it
turns out that that's actually enough to
let you deal with errors if I if I'm
trying to decide which of these two is
correct in the presence of errors you
can show that because each of these
paths is basically a random walk on an
expander it will probably won't no
errors will sort of aggregate in a nasty
way on any path and it turns out us and
you can make that River those are just a
flavors of the ideas and that's
basically the end of my talk I just
wanted to reiterate the moral of the
story is that if the inner code has
decent something then so does the
expander code and I hope that you will
help me fill in more something's and I
gave two examples locality and list
recoverability they're a bunch of open
questions so one the I think most
pressing but what other properties can I
shove into this I think would be very
interesting to handle list recovery with
errors so that little caveat that I was
saying when I had erasers instead of
errors if we could do errors then I
think that that would lead to some
definitely improved algorithms for for
mr. coding
other applications for less recovery
with erasers and also better
instantiations of these so everything
that i said was sort of living in in
assam topi and I didn't say with the
constants word of this audience because
I would be embarrassed they're quite bad
so actually making these implementable
um i think is a very interesting way
that's all I've say thanks